madame monsieur bonsoir la stupeur la
colère et l'indignation à grande synthe
dans la banlieue de dunkerque où cet
après midi se déroulait une marche
silencieuse en mémoire de ce jeune homme
de 17 ans pris pour cible parce qu'il
était d'origine maghrébine un crime
raciste qui aurait pu faire d'autres
victimes
l'homme muni d'un fusil a tiré à
plusieurs reprises contre des cafés
fréquentée essentiellement par des
jeunes issus de l'immigration blessant
plusieurs personnes le meurtrier
toujours en fuite ce qui ajoute à la
tension palpable cet après-midi dans le
quartier pour les réguliers en dominique
maes patrick sur tarn
moins de 24 heures après la mort de
mohamed cette marche s'est organisée
spontanément cet après-midi dans les
rues de grande synthe
une marche qui a frôlé l'incident des
journalistes et des policiers ont
notamment été pris à partie le drame et
il est vrai tout frais dans les mémoires
hier soir vers 21h un inconnu au volant
d'un 4 4 s'arrête sur cette place bordée
de commerces
armé d'un fusil de chasse il vise un
groupe de passants d'origine maghrébine
ils tirent nos ahmed 17 ans est
mortellement touché
j'étais juste derrière j'ai entendu les
deux coups de feu le jeune a est
apparemment plein visage
il a couru jusque derrière il s'est
effondré puits de secours sont arrivés
et personne n'a pu arrêter le tir
amenant personnes vous êtes en train de
me questionner jeu c'est possible que
quelqu'un nous tirent dessus comme ça
quand de la passe dépendent normals à
trois quarts d'heures auparavant dans ce
quartier de dunkerque tout proche le
même tir au volant de la même voiture
avait déjà blessé trois clients dans ce
café un café là aussi fréquenté par des
maghrébins le crime raciste fait donc
peu de doute et ce matin le préfet du
nord s'est rendu sur place pour exprimer
sa solidarité aux familles et deuxième
point que je voudrais fini m'exprimer
c'est ma détermination totale à m nous
avons fait depuis hier soir
depuis que le crime a été commis tous
les moyens je dis bien tous les moyens
dans la justice a besoin pour retrouver
le criminel dans les meilleurs délais
possibles pour les besoins de l'enquêté
plus de 200 hommes dont 30 officiers de
police judiciaire ont été mobilisés dans
le quartier la tension est vive
la population attend des résultats vont
attraper
l'attrapé au mieux pour nous ils font
attraper mais pour l'instant le
meurtrier court toujours
tout ce qu'on sait de lui c'est que
c'est un homme de type européen et qu'il
était hier soir coiffé d'une casquette
de chasse